مع حلول الذكرى الاولى للحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه تعد مصر من اكثر الدول تضررا
احد اهم هذه الاسباب هو ان مصر من اكثر
الدول استيرادا للقمح من الدولتين
المتحاربتين
على مدار عام كامل حاولت الحكومه تامين
القمح فوفق الاحصاءات الرسميه فان مصر
تستورد ما يقرب من الخمسه وعشرين مليون طن
سنويا المسار الاول كان التوجه الى
الاسواق البديله وفي السياق الموازن تم
التوسع في انتاج القمح محليا من خلال
زياده الرقع الزراعيه لزراعه القمح في عدد
من المناطق نزرع مناطق جديده في الصحاري
المصريه بندبر لها المياه اللازمه لها
خلال مشروع توشكا من خلال شرق العوينات
الوادي الجديد هنا في منطقه قليوب يقوم
عدد من المزارعين بزراعه القمح المشكله من
وجهه نظرهم تكمن في القيمه الماليه
الضئيله التي توفرها الحكومه لشراء القمح
المحلي بتستورد القمح من بره بما قمته
1700 دولار فهي بدل ما تستورده من بره
توفر المزارع وهو منه بنفس القيمه هتوفر
له كتير وهتبقى اوفر له الاضراره السلبيه
لم تقتصر على القمح فقط تعطل سلاسل المؤن
التي سببته الحرب على حركه الملاحه
الدوليه بالاضافه الى الانخفاضات المتكرره
بقيمه الجنيه امام الدولار بسبب قرارات
التعويم تسببت في زياده اسعار الكثير من
المواد الغذائيه ارتفاع اسعار الزيوت
والاعلاف تسببت في زياده كبيره على اسعار
اللحوم والدواجن طبعا في حاله الحرب
هترتفع الاسعار عالميا في توقعات ان هي
هتضاعف الاسعار العالميه في ظل كمان زياده
طلب على الحبوب من العديد من الدول العالم
وفي ظل محدوديه الموارد المائيه
اثرت على الاقتصاد في مصر خالد سعر
الدولار يزيد خالد سعر السلع كلها هتزيد
مثلا البانيه كنا بنجيبه مثلا 60 جنيه
امبارح وصل 250 جنيه مثلا وكل حاجه بقى
عماله تزيد في تزايد مستمره وما فيش حاجه
بترخص وفي حين دفعت تداعياته الحرب
الحكومه على ضروره تطبيق سياسه غذائيه
جديده تعتمد على الاكتفاء الذاتي الا ان
انتهاء الحرب في اسرع وقت قد يمثل بارقه
امل لملايين المصريين الذين يعيشون موجات
غلاء غير مسبوقه احمد عثمان العربيه
القاهره